yeah hello and welcome to this video
another tea session and I'm going to
start right away with some games in fact
I already had started a session about 30
minutes ago or something I don't have
much tea left and I am ultimately
deleted that recording because I was
playing against the cheetah and it took
me a little bit too long to really
recognize that I I lost a game pretty
early on and he did a clever job there
yeah my first game I lost but I felt
okay I'm probably rusty and it's my
thing just just play badly second game
he lost like a little child like you
probably the level that he usually plays
on and then again he like clued me three
times straight away and I know that you
guys sometimes like to watch those
videos but I just think it's pointless I
scratched this one and I reported him I
would get the points back and I know
it's a waste of time I really wonder
what people yeah what the pointer was
off of this is anyway so let's play some
games yeah I've got black against GRU
took hits a three plus two game and it's
the black side of the row so lemo wide
he usually goes for a long castling if
he places early Knight c3 the knight c3
usually doesn't really do a good job if
you play for him King side castling and
and Queen side play so I expect him to
Castle queenside now on it's not the
only option but that's what they usually
do
okay now I'm never quite sure if I
should play Knight is 7-1 Knight f6 I
think both is good call 906
now that is a typical in fact your
regrouping in such a position
trying to play a form um
[Music]
eun-young I can just practice should be
set
you
yeah maybe 9h five bit unsure what
exactly I should do
you can also probably just take as well
this could be a position that I've
covered in my Magnus repertoire it's
very much possible I don't really
remember every single line I remember
most of them but sometimes I fail an
interesting question is actually f5
quick PMO's
yeah I feel a bit silly because after
this this cheetah video
I just wonder if I should to tell every
single story again that I told it it's a
bit bit of a thing yeah because I just
was lading what what I did in London I
probably will do it again so I've been
to London and been there mostly for the
chasuble event which was really nice
nice meet up with our people that are
only in you yeah from online contacts
also had a couple of funny entertaining
blitz games with with Simon Williams in
beep later or five games was roughly 50%
I guess I'm not quite sure actually I
don't quite remember if
[Music]
it was 50% or if anybody if somebody had
a plus score um it and you have won the
first two games um anyway it was good
fun and really nice and relaxed evening
um of course I've been down at the time
when
London chess classic the grand chess to
a final was played but interestingly
enough I I never visited to the venue it
just didn't work out
I arrived relatively late on Wednesdays
and I felt really really tired after
after the travel um and I didn't go on
Wednesday thinking okay I can't go on
Thursday and when I checked this a
little bit more closely on Thursday
morning I just recognize that I'm
resting rest day on Thursday and
therefore that didn't really worked as I
thought um okay so I said well then I
could always go on Friday but Friday
also didn't work out for me at least and
the the there was a round of course but
I was just yeah walking London looking
let me check there shouldn't blunder the
house here and would be embarrassing
well five I was going sightseeing a
little bit and also I was going through
them
the main shopping areas there
intending to and just successful intend
to look at a couple of wristwatch wrist
rot wrist watches are really struggling
with that word it's a newly acquired
hobby of mine and I was really good fun
the thing was that I completely
misjudged how long it takes to go from
yeah to travel like with in London
simply because the traffic is so
enormous you sometimes just take a long
while to get to places and in this case
I arrived so late back at at my hotel
there okay it really doesn't make all
that much sense to go to the to the
games so I am I didn't go on Friday as
well but okay I didn't I don't think I
missed all that much games were okay but
nothing
really out of the ordinary yeah
okay this is a bit of a risk but
that makes no sense
I am I wanted to try to trap the Knights
but it's really not something that would
work
now
mm it's probably just to draw right
or let's say very Jewish right word
to draw maybe I'm making a little bit of
progress yeah but nothing
earth-shattering
the shuttering I think oh that is a word
right
okay didn't expect this but
pretty equal but ok I've got a time
advantage
ah
yeah g4 is on the wrong color
probably still shouldn't do anything
nice got 90 form
[Music]
okay
you
anyway I can make
way I don't think so I cannot sacrifice
the porn unfortunately
I go to e5 you
three again
ciao
was really nothing much
Jim
make a draw
[Music]
he will display an
Bishan him yeah probably just a correct
draw nothing much happened here but okay
it was a not the most exciting game but
I could tell my story what's what I did
in London
at least that was not a cheetah game I
really always wonder what those people
are doing
not getting the refund just yet but I
will get it
ultimately zaxon born baguette - hi very
German name could be Austrian right yeah
its Austrian but that could be something
like in southern Germany or Austria in
fact so sorry
you
okay now
I was really costly I lost like 50
points in that friggin match against a
cheetah
oh very nice his thanks for playing
against me I could have written in
German and be an issue
que no
okay and it tooks a bit odd Bishop g4
not happy to take the space
you
hmm interesting yeah
not such an easy decision here because
I'm just keeping the tensioned tension
is probably also not a bad choice
yeah I think I should have a pretty good
structural edge because these pawns
heads it's difficult for black to
arrange them in a way that they are not
weak
really not that easy to do he five
leaves many weakness like d5 and term
we'll see it's not terrible for black
but I think I'm I'm happy about it
Oh
90
[Music]
you
Jim
the trade see'em
I'm gaining a bit of time like Knight
takes Bishop to his Bishop takes Queen
takes the knight has to move again oh
yes suspend a move with it and I'm also
ready to play c5 in such a situation
sometimes quickly which would ya change
the central pawn structure quite
favorably I wonder why he has a decision
here to be honest is there really
something substantially better than
taking it just goes back okay
I expected to happen
you can play efore here but that allows
night d3
not really what you want
rook t1 would be a move
I'm not sure that I actually want to
move and it's done this and I want to
move the rook away from the upper half
open F foul
[Music]
could still could could prove useful
yeah so most of the tea I consumed
during the this cheater session so I'm
not going to just drink a bit of water
not before
I guess we'll see
really consider this at all
but why is it any good I go to b5 then
replace what
some a6 on
you
you
my don't release fear will be seven as
hanging as the problem
desperado on d6 and then kick everything
or take c5 takes d5 takes b5
hmm I don't know
know what's best here
give me this one I'm not quite sure
what's best but this looks pretty strong
actually so take stakes
you know p7 is still hanging
do six still hanging
I just recognized that after taking on
c5 but should be seven he might play
Bishop takes h3
it's still very good for white but
didn't see this
at first okay
it's taking really belong here now I can
take b7 but
and he takes age three
Yemm
I can also simply grep on d6 and play
route d1 it's like the absolutely
easiest way to play I'm already a pawn
up if I'm not missing and d6 and b7 is
hanging it looks like he will probably
lose on time no he managed to play d5
but this I'm just taking
yeah just take everything
okay um now
couple of things I can just
go go go go
the way exactly because every single
option has some
it's plus and minuses I'm going to d5 I
wasn't completely sure I he ran out of
time
yam I think it's just too many pawns I
think he played it a little bit oddly at
first that was certainly not so bad
we're here in this kind of scenario it's
difficult to judge if you should take or
just continue I think taking is fine and
he should just probably trade on c3
going back I don't know looks a little
bit odd
I have probably five in me LM also not
the most obvious movie abut Bishop d7
you can take d4 but after going back I
should always be a bit better at this
kind of structure there's always
weaknesses b7 because C 676 is weak and
so on and you have to before looks like
black ass is crumbling oh that will
actually a mistake
interesting
you
I'm not surprised that many moves are an
advantage like B takes e5 or so but that
this isn't really great ad can go to e6
and and now Bishop e7 is not good yeah
that is surprising
it's the problem exactly who could be
eight and then it's got a six and can
take on before
hmm yeah it's true
so that would have been his opportunity
in the game now the way it was and I'm
better with multiple options okay
3+2 it was right
you
okay let's play the Benko for change
still not my still not my points back I
came he's grabbing everything Bank
awaits a tricky one I mean I I've
written the bank repertoire in 2016 but
and played it at the time quite a bit
but I forgotten running most of it
I remember that this was bad because of
Knight takes d5
the pregame Gelfand against Magnus
[Music]
that game
you
yeah this is ultimately incorrect but
obviously a tricky a tricky position
um now
you
- should take him
so I can take on a tool
interesting now what to do here
you
I just wonder because there are options
too
[Music]
returned material but it's not really
good right bishop everyone that makes no
sense
Quincy for is probably correct
buttoning on f1
he's out for Queen age six
you
let's just stop this for the moment and
he cannot play rupees seven because of
queen f1 check made this whole line is
some by computer standards just winning
four black but you see that in a blitz
game things can be tricky
came um now
Bishop takes
six idea or 95
look f7 looks like
the most obvious choice
six
excuse knew it
Wow
okay
I don't want to spend even more time
ah
here takes take it in between takes rook
g7 then White has a draw with create at
least a draw
a ticket king of âge
and check on age six
Oh
hmm
hmm as is this is a nature in a blitz
game this is a pretty tricky variation
for Schwalm
I wonder if 95 is also possible maybe
a ticket cringy six
ma'am probably draw ever take it this
made on h8 sorry
okay so rook g7 was my initial idea but
this Bishop takes f6
you
[Music]
is the thread actually Queen g6s a
threat
maybe
could also be a threat and I have to
make a move
the ship f6 could work
who takes this made pawn takes this made
you
Bishop f6 is probably winning yeah now
threats
and this is this can this can happen
yeah
I mean this line is just straight up
losing for white but it is something
that it's not so easy to handle them so
but let's just check how I could have
one I mean a tool it should be one so
here I am queen bee three wins
everything else loses yeah it is tricky
it is really tricky so queen bee three
wins Quincy four already loses and he
found exactly the right sequence yeah
rupee one is easy because there were LT
I'm threatening mate and now I don't
have anything ready to do on Queen aged
six it is very dangerous so I have to go
Queen b3 then now we need to find out
the difference and one difference is
probably that I'm on the bishop
that is a key difference so rookie one
this is probably the point you cannot
play queen age six as that you can take
B to the rook is hanging however and I
will take it
so rook e1 makes a lot of sense and now
probably I need a good defensive move
and d6 seems to be the only one that
wins the only move that wins Queen age
six I can take b2
and why can still try like Bishop a1 or
so
Queen a three years again that's like
the only move it's getting down I mean I
looked at this I know that like should
objectively be winning but it is not
easy it's not easy okay let's not spend
ages on this and get a couple of more
games in
and really makes sense if she played
this opening on a regular basis - um -
um check this a little bit Wow I just
see chess Network is playing one bullet
and without increment he's got 2,800 in
bullet now he can be lucky that I'm that
we are not playing in 1+1 now then I
would completely completely take away
his rating this is so much higher so
higher - 857 I don't play bullet without
increment that is just too hectic for me
okay now let's play LZ con and he
wouldn't play me anyway he has over the
years always declined any kind of
suggestion of making a video together
when in fact he doesn't he didn't even
decline it usually doesn't even answer
any message like years ago haven't tried
there for for ages of course
once you know that they're not
interested in anything then you can just
just as well stop
okay now this is a heretic line of the
Catalan Wham
why does some giving up a pawn form
reasonable compensation you are not
better if black plays perfectly but you
always have good play on the queenside
the good thing is that it's fairly easy
to play you just play the moves that I'm
just playing like Bishop f4 Queen b3
centralized rooks and often the pressure
is simply is so strong that you will win
the d4 pawn back so I'm not easy for
black to to handle
so we'll see what black is coming up now
with b7 is hanging I think one way to
play it for black is to play rook c8 and
just ignore that it is actually not easy
to cover you can play Queen c8 but this
is always it it feels very passive this
move
I'm not very intuitive either I'm here
think about Roxy one coming
probably not even good yeah I think they
play rook c8 in this position
okay this is a bit of a surprise anyway
I'm just playing the the moves that I
mentioned just centralized and see what
happens maybe I had something better
here like taking okay now 96 is
something too
I consider
now you've got all kinds of tactics 'i'm
you
liam 96 maybe
not sure there probably a couple of good
continuations
yeah so rooks is seven I thought night
xb7 would be a good consideration
Knight b7 rook takes Knight takes c6
ah
let's do this and not spend hours
ah
should be good Bishop takes Bishop takes
the ruckus almost strapped
ah
ah
King almost trapped now um how do we
handle this should be five maybe
show
I have to shoot you five against you
five
I would mostly what I would like to play
here is to push the pawns forward
hmm
this one prepare B for a four and so on
v5 I have Bishop g5 that should be
pretty annoying
and I'm threatening we should be fired
for sure that would win deform just
straight away
you
Kame say any sort of tactical issue I
don't think so
so it could be form
maybe you just wants to go h6 this is
actually a fair point
did not do this okay so I'll be 5
uh-huh didn't think about the smooth
you
okay
kamme Bishop d2 is not exactly ideal but
what else
you
does he have a better move than taking I
would be surprising
I think Bishop before looks really
annoying okay so he ultimately took
that looks very ambitious
to go III I guess
you
yeah okay let's prepare five
III is big deal
you
come
why he's doing okay supplying this as
well I think well-defended
the opening probably was bad but right
out out of the opening but this is a
well played game by black
intention was to simply sacrifice so
this is something prevented now is III a
possibility or instead I take it does he
have this kind of I don't think so if
teeth if he now can play no
defense
[Music]
nay defended us pretty well I think
so I'll be a pawn up but of course that
is more or less clean draw I took him I
can still I can still try a little bit
look at
Ahn's here
you
yeah
you
now I should take in d3 of course that
was so stupid and I didn't need to do it
in this in this order
and I have zero chances to do anything
absolutely zero
and I can even try to to attack
age three
you
I said wrong button
[Music]
now that was good
I should at least try to pose a couple
of problems and I also must have missed
a pretty substantial advantage I don't
think this is something that black
should survive so night Dec 4 is already
pretty awful okay
and then that means that I have
something better here right I can just
take b6 yeah there should be many good
more said it doesn't look right or
plague did but I'm surprised that I
somehow couldn't get much from here I
have to improve here
yeah the move Queen c4 is not best Queen
b5 is locked better
the idea is quite similar probably but
the issue is that my crook c7 I would
have been okay for him
and the queen is not that well placed
there and if I'm doing this you also
probably may can play e5 technically
speaking but
this is a big difference now because now
I have this
you
that looks that looks a lot better
you
Jim and this is not nice got nightly
form
and I have to play rook c1 these are
these are important resources have this
is a move that I want to play anyway it
makes quite a bit of sense but I got the
order wrong I didn't see this nightly
for me at all and this is completely of
course solving blacks problems
like this even better here because only
my majority is not worth much and he can
push it and he did a good job here
really I was hoping for III when F for
should be good right EMF warm I mean
good yeah I thought um that same not
sure where the queen is going I thought
that I could simply mistakenly thought I
could give up the exchange but he has
clear route h6 at the end yeah this is
very important but okay I can do this
first and then give up the exchange
because this should be giving white some
chances a little bit at least yeah this
is a pretty safe configuration and this
the pawns here in in connection with the
bishop could be dangerous
yeah ultimately we got here I should
have played a five that's true yeah okay
but I also should be able to at least
pose some problems he I mean it's a draw
but I should at least pose some problems
so here
Bishop d5 is right and now I probably
have to do it do it differently
she fought did not look to bear to me at
a five white indigo g5
this apply badly run him
not really setting any any sort of
problem and here h3 is like here here I
have to go King III of course Bishop g8
is just idiotic person idiotic move
yeah I mean again he should draw without
any hassle but I should yeah at least
try try a little bit okay guys I'm going
to stopping the session he had at this
time I as mentioned I already had a
thirty or forty minute one before and I
had to kill it off due to the cheating
and I have to do something now so I'm
going to stop it right here I hope you
have a good Sunday this will be the day
of the release thanks for watching I'll
be back tomorrow I guess bye bye
you